[Music]
do
right technology it's a wonderful thing
isn't it
okay so welcome everybody to this uh to
this hearing this morning
um held under section 181 of
the local government act
relating to 213 beach road kaiapoi
i'll just get some introductions done
around the table
before start my name is neville atkinson
i am the chair
of this hearing
and to my left i have
counsel paul williams
and to my right
counselor phil redmond
and i will get others around the room
whom i'm assuming technology has picked
up to introduce themselves
if you wouldn't mind sarah starting now
sarah nichols is our uh secretary for
today
and will be uh will be assisting us
in that manner
uh good morning everybody my name's
kelly simpson i'm the three waters
manager at the waimakariri district
council
morena everyone my name is jenny ecker
i'm part of the property team at
waimakariri district council
council
and
thanks
kelly
and we have
also
mrs winter
at that the rear of the uh the room as
well as who i'm sure is visible
to you
um
and now if we can get uh
our
um
zoom participants to introduce
themselves would be helpful thank you
my name is george forbes and i'm a
partner at roads and co representing
karen winterfell thank you mr forbes
and i'm rod kerr i'm the delivery
manager of the shovel ready program
with the waianae micro registry council
thank you rob
okay do we have any apologies for for
today there are none that i'm aware of
there are none to be recorded
any conflicts of interest that need to
be recorded or have not been mentioned
so far
there appear to be none
so mr forbes we will we will get you to
present to us what you have for us if
you wouldn't mind thank you
thank you
mr chair and panel members can i just
ensure that you can hear me
i'm a solicitor
the registered owner of the property
located at 213 beach road cardboard
and i present the submission for our
client
karen winter was issued a notice dated
21 september 2021
from the council in respect of
constructing works on and under her land
including significant permanent
structures
that will remain on and under the land
following completion of works
i refer here to these works as the
proposed works
our client lodged an objection to the
notice pursuant to schedule 12
of the local government act on 21
october 2021
advising the council that
she does not consent to the proposed
works
and no permission is granted to enter
upon the land for any purpose associated
with the proposed works
before we move on to karen winter's
reasons for her objection
it is apt to touch on the purpose of
section 181
of the local government act
which was discussed by collins jay
in the high court
in the case hut city council
versus the lower hutt district court and
castles
and the reference for that is 2013
nzhc
in that case the court held that
section 181 strives to achieve a careful
balance
of council powers with the rights of
private property owners to use and enjoy
their property
free from unreasonable interference
this balance was achieved in five
discreet ways
limiting the council powers in order to
reinforce private property owner
protections
requiring that works be necessary which
is a two-fold analysis
up question other works necessarily on
private land and if so how can such
works be undertaken in a manner that
minimizes interference with the rights
of anona
the consent or schedule 12 notice
objection and appeal procedure for
utilizing land
the requirement that council act
reasonably
in an administrative law sets and
finally
the interface with the public works act
1981 regime in respect of compensation
in this case the proposed works do not
represent a mere construction right
instead
this land is effectively being acquired
and they do and it does not represent
the careful balance envisaged by section
instead the design means that these
works are unreal and unreasonable
interference with the rights of a
private property owner to use and enjoy
their property
free from that unreasonable interference
karen winter's objection is based on
several grounds as outlined in a written
objection of 21 october 2021
most of which are overlapping on a
premise upon the council's proposed
works not being in line with the purpose
of section 181 of the local government
act
first due to the heavy machinery and
people transit required during the
construction phase we consider that
karen winter will be unable to use a
larger area of the land
than the actual final proposed works
area
for her ordinary livestock business
purpose
including because of the dangers of
cattle fright and with that the
resulting people and property danger
associated with every heavy machinery
transit in use
at the least
the construction phase may render karen
winter's land unusable unusable for the
usual stock numbers
normally run on the land
the council has stated in its agenda for
this hearing that quote
works shall be undertaken by excavator
and other earthworks machinery
within this area
no temporary working space is necessary
outside the area in quote
respectfully this does not seem feasible
for example
the council will have to put up a fence
alongside and away from the works
perimeter
in an area where livestock graze and we
would expect the placement of that fence
would involve intrusion onto the balance
of karen winter's land
this follows on to our client's second
reason for her objection
the lack of council explain explanation
the council has not adequately explained
in writing
how it is the proposed works affect the
land including detailed proposals to
minimize interference with the balance
of the lander with livestock during the
proposed construction phase
as noted the presence of construction of
the proposed works
over a portion of ms winter's land
will make that land unsuitable for
livestock grazing
and the usual business conducted on the
land
it is noted that the council has stated
in the agenda report that quote
livestock will move away from the work
site during this period
the work site will be fenced to prevent
stock access and to ensure safety and
quote
the council has not made clear where
miss winter's livestock will be moved
during this period
the council has not outlined a proposed
start date for proposed works nor the
length of time that construction is
likely to continue
that absence of information may stop
buying and planning difficult indeed and
it is unreasonable in the context of
land that is presently used for
livestock raising purposes
further we say the council has not
adequately explained why the proposed
works
whether some or all
must be completed on this land rather
than any public land or other land
the agenda which was only sent outside
only sent
outside working hours last thursday
evening
outlined for the first time for our
client an assessment of alternative
options considered by the council
the reasoning there for preferring our
clients land included that quote the
alternate option is more expensive in
quote
although no detail is provided for an
objective proportionality assessment to
be undertaken
further the scorecard framework used by
the council is not detailed
for our client or for any non-council
party to be able to assess or determine
objectively whether the analysis or
alternate location options has in fact
been adequate
additionally the council has not
beyond stating that compensation may be
available at
provided any detail of the
compensationary process or arrangements
the lack of detail from the council as
to compensation leaves our client
unable to adequately consider the
council's proposal
a third basis for our clients objection
as referred to earlier is that due to
their nature and extent the proposed
works are outside the scope of the
intention of the statutory commission
under the local government act and the
land would be more properly pursued as
an acquisition under the public works
act 1981
significant in this case is the
permanency of the proposed works
combined with our clients
future inability to access use and enjoy
a substantial area of land after
construction of their proposed works
for these reasons we say the council
does not enjoy sufficient authority
under section 181 of the local
government act to construct the proposed
works in the way that it wishes
and the local government act should not
be used for mere expediency or cost
saving especially given our clients
entitlements would be broader if the
land was legally acquired
in
under the public works act with
compensation accounting for
a loss of land disturbance
and the loss of potential of land
in considering the notice the proposed
works and the points i we have noted our
client considers that the council is
acting unreasonably as a matter of
administrative law by failing to take
into account the considerations we
outlined when utilizing section 181 of
the local government act
when it worked properly to be used in
the public works act acquisition
procedure we consider the existence of
this alternate statutory route to the
local government act would inform the
district council in any appeal of a
decision by the council to progress
and further
an unreasonable decision may be set
aside by the high court when exercising
its judicial review jurisdiction
in conclusion therefore
our client objects to the council's
proposed works
and no permission is granted to enter
upon the land for his purpose
she respectfully asks that the council
abandoned the proposed works as planned
finally we note that should council
decide to progress with the proposed
works
we expect that our client will have no
choice but to consider her appeal option
in the district court as well as in
higher courts as permitted
thank you that brings my submission to a
close thank you mr forbes uh questions
panel
council
any questions
i have none
are there any questions
mr forbes
there appear to be no questions mr ford
so that you've obviously stated the case
very plainly thank you very much for
that
um we will now move to uh mr kerr if you
would uh present your report please
thank you mr chairman uh so with me i
have uh kelly simpson and jenny akers
and rob hawthorne who are able to answer
questions as well from their
respective expertise
but i'll just summarise the report as it
stands
and then allow you to explore any any
matters within it that uh that you made
so
um as you're aware on the third of
august council resolve to exercise its
powers on the section 101 of the local
government act
um
to give notice to the land owner of 213
beach road
it's intended to undertake land drainage
of storm water works from the land bend
the beach road stormwater pumping
station pressure main and flood
protection button so
there are three elements to then propose
works
the purpose of the works is improve the
level of flood protection for the urban
area
uh the notice issued under section 181
and the description of work system is
included as appendix a
uh or attachment a uh to the report and
that was the same information sent to
the landowner also put on display within
the kai boy service centre
that notice was sent on the 21st of
september
it was put on the council's website as
well and publicised on the council's
facebook page to ensure that everybody
had the opportunity to see it
the one month the one month period uh
set out in uh schedule 12 of the act
expired on the 22nd of october which was
the
objection period uh
as
as we're aware and as mr forbes outlined
the landowner provided that objection on
the 24th 21st of october
and that is included as attachment b
and obviously has been summarized by
most forbes
the
we're here now
so
the next paragraph of my notes is to say
that the hearing is set down for
for today and
you also have a deliberation period
and a week today as well next tuesday
the
the options that you have to consider
is under the under the act is to either
abandon the works proposed or to proceed
with the works proposed with or without
any alterations that you see fit
so you do have options in terms of
amending
the proposal
the key matters which i suggest that you
consider in which we've addressed in the
staff report
are around the necessity for the works
and we've provided you with some
analysis of that
the consideration of the landowner
objection of what you of course just
heard
and
any alterations
that you might wish to make as a result
of those considerations
so
i'm
happy to answer any questions
and for you to explore any other aspects
of the of the report supported by
the other staff
at the hearing
back to you mr chairman
yeah thank you mr kirk
um
handling me
any questions mr edward i've lost my
thought oh
come this come countryside sorry we've
had a another technical
uh glitch mr redmond has dropped off the
uh dropped off the zoo so he will join
myspace
right did you have any questions
uh
mr kerr are there alternative
proposals to the one that you're putting
forward here
that could meet the same outcome
so we've given uh at the uh in the
attachments of the report
some an analysis of those potential
options um and if i
can take you to the right attachment but
i'm sure you can probably find it
so
we have looked at uh the options both on
um other
on on public land and on other private
land as well so clearly the works on
other private lands such as on the north
side of the beach road
has the same
process
and requirements as the discussion we're
having
with 213 beach road with ms winter
the
the works on private land are all
difficult if not impossible and that is
simply because of the lack of space
so the
the best next option
which if there was enough space would be
would be the one that we would wish to
pursue would be
right at the head of feldrik drain and
if you know the site is exactly where
the
uh current
foot bridge is
over failed with drain at the head of
the head of the drain
however we've looked in
at that and sought to try and fit it all
in however it is a very narrow spot and
has a high speed road next door to it
and the risks and there aren't sorry the
third aspect is that there is a major
wastewater pipeline which goes through
that area as well
and so the challenges of actually
fitting that in
uh
mean that
it's either not feasible or very very
high risk
in order to be able to be achieved
the other
potential area in public works land is
further
west along beach road in the verge
however that carries the same problems
and in fact carries quite a significant
safety risk of being on on the edge of
the road in that in that way so
our conclusions are as
as set out in that analysis is that they
all the alternative options carry some
quite
a significant
disadvantages and the ones on public
land we don't believe are actually
feasible
so that's that is why we've um concluded
that
the location that is set out in the
proposed works is the
better location and the only realistic
location within
within this area
i might add the the reason why it is in
this location and perhaps
not at the southern end of the river end
of outlook drain and so on is simply
because of the hydraulics
and the way the system performs is that
the pumping station needs to be located
nearer to the area which is at flood
risk which is
the most prone is the area around
bracebridge street and so moving it
further away from this location perhaps
downstream i mean
means that
it is either less effective or becomes
uh
ineffective
in resolving that flood risk
thank you rob
when i was looking at the diagram there
is also a bond for bund
however you pronounce it proposed
running north to south
yes it is that bond essential
for the
proposal or
how critical to the proposal is it and
secondly
down the river end of that bond
it appears to remain in karen winter's
property
there is
appeared to be land to the left of that
the ownership of which i i'm not aware
of
is there any reason why there's that
kink in the bond or whether it could go
straight straight ahead
uh so
if so
to answer the first question in terms of
the necessity for that um
the
bundle bond b
is
the
it creates the purpose of it is create a
separation between
the macintosh drain catchment and any
outer bank flow that comes from
macintosh drain and the urban area of
kaiapoi
so
it's part of the overall scheme it's not
directly connected with the pumping
station these things work together as
supposed to be
in complementary
um
so
it is part of the proposed works but
it's not part of the pump station as
such as part of
that the overall scheme to protect kyboy
from uh and the urban area kind way for
flooding
the
answer to the second question is
the land to
the immediate
east of falden drain down at the
southern end
there is part of the former residential
red zone
and is now now owned by council
that is within the
license
area or the agreement the area covered
by the agreement with well
with the aqua sports park
developers
our discussions with them is that
there is some potential for
putting the bund along there but that
hasn't been fully explored however
my reading of the agreement that the
council has with
uh
uh with well is that there is the
ability for council to
have those works there and indeed in
their master plan
for that area it is a glamping area so
therefore without being too simplistic
about it some
local land raising is not a significant
impairment in fact may be quite
advantageous to their plans
what the the disadvantages aside from
that integration with that future
development is that there would be some
loss of
a couple of large trees um by running
the bun through that area but that is um
that's the only other disadvantage
thank you ryan thank you rob
could you just confirm
[Music]
having a way for them
that's much better right
just to simply pop potter
without the bond the effect on
karen winter's property would be greatly
minimized
would the drainage
objects
be achieved without the bond
so there's
there's two parts to
the
flood protection
improvement the flood improvement that
are achieved by the proposed works
the first is the construction of the
pumping station and of course the
pipeline to convey
water from the pumping station to the
river
and that
provides a greater level of protection
to
properties which are currently at risk
of flooding in the brass bridge street
area
so that is rain that is falling on the
urban area and is unable to get away and
instead ponds
around that area
and therefore the pumping station will
increase the rate of discharge and
therefore reduce the amount of flooding
so that's that's
that's what the pump station does
the bund
uh protects the urban area by different
means and that it prevents
water from the macintosh drain flowing
into the urban area
and therefore obviously flooding that
urban area
so there's two parts to the scheme that
protects from two different types of
flood risk
and event for the um stop here
where would you visit the fence line to
be on the bundle
or where abouts
so i can only just just hear you cancel
it but
i understand that the question was where
would the fence line be would it be on
the boundary or on the bond
and
aside from i think this can be a
discussion that could take place in the
detail of
where a landowner
would prefer to have the fence
but there actually doesn't need to be a
fence
around on the bundle to protect the bund
it's a grass
mound if you like a long one obviously
but a mound and there will be no reason
why
you wouldn't necessarily have cattle
on top of the bund eating the grass and
and having a nice view so
it doesn't have to be a fence off the
only area that needs to be fenced off
solely for safety purposes is around the
pumping station to ensure that everybody
is safe
thank
you you i have no questions mr forbes
any questions just here
thank you no i don't have any questions
well look that that concludes
all the presentations that we had so i
will adjourn the hearing and we will
adjourn to deliberations on the ninth
of which we will hold here
and we will be back to you in writing
with the
with the hearing panel's decision um
directly after that as soon as we can
thank you very much for your your
attendance
participation
um and uh you will be hearing from us in
due course thank you very much
thank you
[Music]